here's a curious statistic the pandemic
has been good yes good for
time asleep this chart shows electricity
usage
by hour across the day it's collected by
energy supplier bulb
using their network of tens of thousands
of smart meters which they've
exclusively shared with us
now the dark blue line is the last week
of january 2020
before the pandemic the lightning line
is the last week of january 2021 so
during the pandemic
and you can see back before the pandemic
electricity usage
picked in the morning around 7 30.
now it doesn't get going really until
about nine o'clock and the daytime peak
is around lunch there are lots of
individual variations of course
but overall the uk is having a lion
the one upside of the pandemic now you
might be wondering
why i'm telling you this well it's
because we can use this data
to see whether people are staying in
during lockdown
this chart shows all the households who
use more energy at lunch time
than they used in the morning just as
you would if you were going out to work
you can see during the first lockdown
that number fell very rapidly
then it rose again over the summer as
the prime minister urged people to go
back to work
the second lockdown honestly didn't have
much of an impact
and the third lockdown is somewhere
between lockdown one and two
but and this is the important bit look
over here
the number of households going out to
work is going
up since the start of lockdown
by this measure and it's just one
measure lockdown is
losing its grip on the working
population
now you might wonder is this kind of
going out
as measured by your electricity usage is
that correlated with a rise in cases
well this chart suggests that maybe it
is this is a chart
of people who go out to work in london
versus the rest of the uk
london's in light blue and you can see
far fewer people in london
go out to work now the crucial period
is this period in september and
in august and september epidemiologists
were really puzzled
why cases were rising in the rest of the
country but not in london the most
densely packed city in the uk well
here's the answer well here's the answer
we think
far fewer people were going out to work
in london
in this period than the rest of the uk
now of course this measure isn't perfect
we all know that london has been here
really hard in both the first wave
and the second wave with the new variant
but there is some
evidence to suggest that in london
there is some perhaps additional
protection because there are far
many more service jobs than people who
can stay at home
now back to the present you might say
well
hang on if lockdown is weaker then why
are cases in hospitals going and
hospital emissions
going down and the answer is honestly
that we don't really know
but here's one thing that is interesting
the office for national statistics
survey which is normally considered our
most reliable measure of the state of
the pandemic
that shows that cases aren't falling
very fast
in fact they're decreasing quite
gradually and they're still
very high now why that discrepancy
i've spoken to government scientists
about this and they say that one
possible reason
could be that younger people aren't
getting tested
and the data we've seen today suggest
that might be
because they're going out to work it's
just a theory
but the government will be worried by
data like this
because even though the news about the
vaccine is good the risk of new variants
is high they want everyone to keep on
lying in
a bit longer